all right so you've seen the unboxing
now it's time for the breakdown what is
using the Apple Vision Pro actually
like this is easily one of Apple's
craziest most radical possibly dystopian
products of all time and I have a lot of
thoughts here like I've been using it
for about a week now there are some
parts of this thing that are absolutely
incredible and some other parts that
feel weird or borderline unfinished
there are all kinds of new technologies
from a new operating system to infrared
eye tracking to virtually reconstructed
versions of you I feel like there are so
many actually new things that you have
to understand in order to get a sense of
what this headset actually is and what
it does so I'm going to break this down
into two parts this video is all about
using the Vision Pro it's everything
I've learned from the past week of
wearing and getting used to this thing
every single day but I'm also working on
a more wide ranging possibly more
existential review video but let's just
start with the more Hardware
fundamentals right like what is this
thing that I'm holding literally Apple
Vision Pro at its core well it is a VR
headset now Apple would never say that
and they probably won't like that I'm
saying that word you know I made an
entire video about why they refuse to
use those words and they're calling it
spatial Computing instead we'll get
there but the truth is it's a really
really really high-end virtual reality
headset it's it's something we've seen
before right it's got displays and
lenses and speakers and fans and buttons
and this is a form factor this is a
thing that we have seen before but
before I even turn this thing on there
are clearly several things that are a
little different about this one so first
of all it's made of metal lots of metal
and glass here which are high quality
but heavy materials relative ly speaking
so there's this precisely machined
aluminum frame around the outside and
yes those are intakes for fans at the
bottom and then vents for those fans at
the top on the right side there's your
digital crown that can be pressed in or
turned and then on the other side is
just a single larger button so kind of
basically the same two buttons as an
Apple Watch and then when you get a
little further back on this band here
these little pods with downward facing
grills these are speakers which are
pointed straight at your ears and work
surprisingly well though of course it
also means means that people around you
can hear a little bit of what you're
hearing there's a little bit of bleed
and I have a lot to say about spatial
audio so stay tuned for that but the
main event is at the front there is an
enormous piece of glass which yes is
very easy to fingerprint and smudge and
then behind that thing there's this
outward facing OLED display and a bunch
of sensors all the way around outside
facing sensors that go forward sideways
and straight down there's depth sensors
infrared illuminators light l r scanners
and just regular old RGB cameras all
being processed by an M2 Chip and an R1
chip inside this thing and then maybe
the craziest part inside the headset
there are a bunch more sensors facing
your eyes tracking your eyes in real
time for all the eye control and
everything that comes with that and also
then to display a representation of your
eyes on the outside of the
headset kind of we get there but overall
when you put it all together you get a
very wellmade very high-end but also
pretty heavy computer to wear on your
face uh so officially this this headset
with this solo knit band when I weighed
it showed up as 638 G which some of you
on Twitter have already pointed out is
actually slightly less than the plastic
meta Quest Pro but that Quest Pro also
has a lot of battery on the back of your
head as a sort of a counterbalance so
the weight distribution is very
different also the quest Pro is not that
comfortable anyway but the point is this
for Apple made the choice of taking the
battery off of the headset which means
okay now there's nothing on the back of
your head so you can wear it and lean up
against things and that might be an
upside but that also now means you have
to deal with this cable all the time
running up to your head and the fact
that it's very front weighted now all of
the weight is on the front of your face
so this is the battery uh as you saw in
the unboxing if you haven't already seen
the unboxing that just went up I'll link
below the like button but this battery
is a surprisingly small
3,366 Mah hours I say surprisingly small
because a normal battery Bank of this
size you might expect to be 10 15 20,000
Mah hours I suspect there's a lot of uh
heat insulation happening here but it
comes with a non- removable 4ft cable
and a proprietary connector at the end
of the cable that will twist and lock to
the headset and so the lock is really
solid it makes sense that it's not just
straight USB that could get disconnected
easily once you connect it it starts
glowing and then it starts booting up
and there's even a little Apple logo
that displays on the outside screen
while it takes you know a little under a
minute to turn on so there is no on or
off button or switch anywhere on this
headset maybe kind of like airpods Max
or something like that so if you ever
take the headset off and put it down it
will enter a standby mode after some
time but it won't turn off if you want
to turn it off you literally have to
twist and unplug the cable that's the
only way to actually turn the headset
off now famous already the battery life
with this included battery is not super
long on this headset 2 to 4 hours is
actually realistic for what you can
expect for just like this built-in
battery but that's also kind of right in
line with a lot of other VR headsets
battery life on VR headsets is not that
great in general if you do want to use
it longer the only way to do that is
there's a USBC port on the battery and
you have to plug the battery in so you
could plug the battery into the wall for
infinite battery life or I guess you
could plug it into like a you could
Daisy chain another battery into the
other pocket or something for even
longer life but yeah 2 to 4 hours now at
first it seemed weird to me that the
port is on the same side of the battery
as the non- removable cable but I think
it's because they just want you to
default to putting this battery like in
your pocket probably in your back pocket
so even if it's plugged into the wall it
can still be in your back pocket you're
just going to want to get a longer USBC
cable so there are no controllers that
come with this headset now it does
support other input methods that are
like game control and mouse and keyboard
and those can be incredibly useful but
by default the primary input method for
everyone using the Vision Pro is your
eyes and your hands so the first time
you put on this headset it goes through
this calibration process and it's pretty
interesting so the first time you ever
put it on it first adjusts the distance
between the lenses physically moving
them inside the headset to match the
distance between your eyes then it does
a sort of a hand scan so it understands
your hands and then you go through this
process of basic basically looking at a
bunch of dots all the way around the
screen and then tapping your fingers
together to select them kind of feels
like an eye test or something and then
you're in so first thing you're going to
notice is you can actually kind of put
your hands anywhere as long as the
headset can see this just your fingers
touching together so there's a lot of
pictures of of people like using a
headset with their fingers like out in
front of them pinching like that but you
actually don't have to do that it's such
a wide angle because of the sensors
facing forward and sideways and down you
can kind of just rest your hand anywhere
in front of you in your lap as long as
you pinch like that it can generally
pick it up which is impressive so you're
pinching to control anywhere in that
180° bubble in front of you and then the
digital Crown you hit that once and the
app drawer comes up pretty simple
doesn't seem that impressive but this is
actually a peek at the first really
impressive thing about this headset to
me which is it seems to have incredible
spatial positioning lock and like it's
really hard to show like have you
appreciate this through a YouTube video
reviewing VR headsets is hard but like
turn around in the room you're in and
like picture a a wall or a window just
appearing locked in place in 3D space in
your room and no matter how much you
move your head or move around it stays
exactly kind of floating where it's
supposed to be but when I say floating I
think you're picturing like a a soft
float but it's locked and that's how it
starts so now you're in Apple's new
vision OS I would describe this as kind
of similar to iPad OS but way more
glassy and like of course with the extra
dimension of 3D space so hitting a
digital Crown will always get the app
drawer back in front of you and then
simply look at the icon you want and
pinch your fingers together to select it
and open that app scrolling is basically
as you'd expect you just kind of pinch
and grab in the air and then pull as if
it's on a string and physics let you
pull things through the air it's pretty
intuitive it's responsive it's fluid
sometimes it's kind of bouncy even I
would say the biggest adjustment is only
being able to control exactly what
you're looking at and I don't think
people realize how often they're
controlling things that they're not
exactly looking directly at with other
computers and other uis but with this
you can look at the button to select it
and if you look at the next thing you're
going to do you're no longer controlling
the button you have to look exactly
where you're trying to interact with
things takes a few extra brain Cycles to
remember to always be looking exactly at
the thing you're controlling so when you
open a window of a vision OS app like
any one of the default Apple apps here
it locks into place it's floating there
it kind of looks again like an iPad app
but very glassy like this frosted glass
around the UI sort of lets you see
through a little bit to the color behind
it and it even sometimes casts a shadow
on the ground in the correct zspace so
it really solidifies that it's floating
in front of you all of this makes it
feel like the window is in the space
around you then if you look at the
bottom of the window you get a little
bar you can always just look at that bar
and pinch to drag it around so drag it
Forward backward anywhere you want in XY
and Z space and then let go and it just
stays absolutely locked and then you can
look at either bottom corner to resize
to make it bigger or smaller and then
finally there's a little X at the bottom
you select that that closes it so that
is the basics of vision OS and just
using an app now this entire time by
default and almost anytime they can pass
through is on which means you have the
headset on but you can see with the
cameras right through to everything
around you and I think this is where
Apple really wants to normalize the term
spatial Computing because it feels like
augmented reality it feels like you're
always able to see the space around you
but technically it's not actually AR
because you are still looking at a
reconstructed version through a camera
feed of the world around you instead of
the actual world around you but maybe
it's all just semantics I will say this
is the best pass through of any VR
headset I have ever used and it's not
even that close now again it's it's so
hard to get this through a YouTube video
I I it does have screen recording built
in so I'm going to try to use that but
imagine putting a headset on and not
really feeling like you're looking at a
screen with the real world because of
the pixel density because of the 90 HZ
refresh rate and because of the
impressive dynamic range of the cameras
and the correctly adjusting shutter
speed you just almost don't you almost
just feel like you're looking at the
real world not through a headset also
the pass through is so close to real
time that I could legitimately interact
with all kinds of things I could catch
items flying at me I even tried playing
pingpong it was easy no hesitation so
officially the R1 chip is doing all the
processing of all this stuff and
adjusting the shutter speed for
different lighting conditions and always
keeping pass through latency Under 12
milliseconds which is the lowest in the
industry but it's it's really combined
that with how close to reality the
colors and brightness and everything are
that keeps it feeling kind of real
basically the only noticeable
restriction is super close-up items and
objects can get a bit blurry and then
you can't quite make out like really
small or fine text so you can't like
read an email or tiny text on your phone
in your hand but you can absolutely text
people or read your notifications while
keeping the headset on if you've tried
other VR headsets you know how
impressive that is it's just it's really
good with the Tech that exists now for
VR headsets uh but you can definitely
still take the headset off and be like
oh it's way brighter in here than I
thought it was either way that's all
pass through but if you ever want to
fully immerse yourself I mean it is a VR
headset after all all you got to do is
uh rotate this digital Crown clockwise
just keep turning it and it will slowly
dial your environment more and more into
your field of view until you dial it all
the way up to fully surrounding you so
all the windows you might have had open
will still stay stuck where they were
but everything you're doing is just on
the moon now so yeah there's a couple
environments Apple has built in here
most of them relaxing Scenic locations
like in California somewhere or one
really nice one is Mount Hood with a
little bit of rainf falling they're not
quite photo realistic but they're just
short of photorealistic like they're the
most realistic digital environments that
I've seen so then the last two big
quirks of the UI control center so the
only way to get to control center is to
look up like and you can't just look up
but you have to physically turn your
head up and look at this arrow that
appears above you so once you see that
you select that and then you get your
control center for things like you know
battery life and notifications Focus
modes and screen recording and pairing
to a Mac but the other big Quirk is text
input so you might be wondering how does
text input work with no physical
controllers uh so there's basic
basically three ways to do this so let's
say you're in Safari and you want to go
to MKBHD
docomond hoodies for the rest of winter
great how do you do it so the first way
is to literally hunt and Peck poking the
keys on the keyboard that appears in the
air in front of you so this one is tough
because it literally only reacts to your
pointer finger on each hand so you
actually can't type fast like with home
row or anything like that not great the
second way though I think is actually
kind of good it's at least faster which
is looking at the key you want to
interact with and then pinching to
select it so just looking at looking
around the keyboard like this and
selecting the keys and you might be
surprised how fast you can type like
this if you actually know your way
around a keyboard pretty well I actually
prefer this to poking the virtual keys
because I at least get a little bit of
haptic feedback from my own fingers
tapping together but then in Safari the
last way to do it is literally to just
look up at the microphone and say the
URL out loud mkb.com and then it just
hears you and goes to the site pretty
quick if it's a URL that you know you
can actually say out loud so what can
you actually do with this thing like now
that we know what it is it's the M2 Chip
a computer on your face with the
displays and the lenses inside and all
sorts of sensors everywhere what can
this thing actually do and I feel like
the most common way to phrase that is
what is the killer app because that's we
feel like we need some sort of
justification to spend 3 4,000
on this thing like applications made the
iPhone what it is as we know it like
apps made the iPad so what is the app
situation on the Vision
Pro so there are two types of apps on
the Vision Pro actually the first is
apps that are built specifically for the
Vision Pro to take advantage of its
awesome experiences and there are a few
of those right now and then there are
all the other apps which basically are
iPhone and iPad apps that happen to be
be compatible because the developer
didn't opt out and the first kind is way
cooler so these are Apple's stock apps
here that come with the Vision Pro and
so these are all of course made just for
Vision Pro so they're going to have
stuff that takes full advantage of what
this thing is capable of Apple music is
a pretty classic one like it has all the
same functionality of any other Apple
music app but in this super glassy
frosted window and shows the colors of
whatever's behind it and you have the
sort of sorting menu on the left hand
side instead of across the bottom that's
the basic layout same thing with the
notes app and the settings app very
glassy almost looking like an iPad app
in the air just rebuilt with this new
material design and then there's the
media apps so Apple TV and Disney plus
they both come pre-installed which they
have built entire environments inside of
them for watching media and there's even
a small collection of videos on the
Apple TV app that are shot on a new
proprietary format specifically for
Vision Pro so it it drops you into a
space with a full 180° video and Alicia
Keys walks right up to you and starts
singing right to your face it's crazy
there's also the photos app which will
let you look at like panoramic photos
for example in this fully immersive view
so you can blow them up to full screen
and then it gives you a bit of a
parallax effect around the edges so it
feels like you're like looking into a
window of your own photo and looking
around it's kind of incredible and then
there's also some other really fun third
part apps that I've tried that were
built ahead of time so sky guide this is
a good one you can look around a real
representation of the sky around you or
any of the you know constellations would
normally be you can look at it a little
longer and it'll pop it out you can pull
it out of the sky to get more
information about it it's a pretty great
idea there's another one called jigspace
which is it's a sick app I don't know if
I'd ever use it but basically it lets
you load 3D models into the space you're
in and mess around with them take them
apart view them in actual size and this
really takes advantage of how good the
placement lock is on the Vision Pro and
you know you can walk around and really
gets you a better understanding of the
scale of things that you don't get to
see up close very often and then keynote
is another funny one so you can of
course go through and edit a keynote
just like normal if you want to but then
they've built this whole environment for
practicing your presentation skills so
you press that and it says oh would you
like to go to a conference room or the
literal Steve Jobs theater so you can
rehearse talking to your audience with
your keynote slides behind you it is
genuinely incredibly immersive and
there's already a bunch more apps like
this in the app store already at launch
that are specifically built for Vision
Pro so they'll take advantage of its
various strengths now are any of these a
killer
app not really I mean I don't if you're
if you're looking for any one of these
to be the reason why you spend like
$4,000 on this headset I don't think we
have that yet but then at least there's
all the other non-native but technically
still compatible apps that are in the
App Store and these are going to look
just like iPhone and iPad apps actually
there's a pre-installed folder on the
home screen when you get this thing
literally called compatible apps and
there's a bunch of them from Apple here
they look exactly like iPad apps I'm
surprised actually that more of them
aren't fully built out to take advantage
of Vision Pro but like Apple Maps is
just the iPad app and so it would be
cool if there were some like fun
augmented reality overlay walking
directions type stuff but nope it's all
the exact same functionality that you
would find if you open this app on your
iPad and you can go to the App Store and
search a bunch of the names of apps you
already know and love and find them by
name and grab them and they'll work the
exact same way crazily enough though
there are already some notable
exceptions uh no Netflix app for The
Vision Pro no YouTube app for The Vision
Pro no Spotify app for The Vision Pro
Apple
has a kind of a contentious relationship
with a lot of developers right now
especially some of the bigger ones um
and so some have made the active choice
to opt out they're like we don't want to
be there this won't be a big enough
platform to matter to us to justify the
work so they're not there now I totally
get it but also now as a Vision Pro
owner and someone who's using it I'm
like oh it's kind of a bummer I really
wanted to be able to watch like a
Netflix show offline download it ahead
of time but you can't do that now but at
least at least for now for the record
you can use the browser and anything
that would work in the browser so if you
pull up Safari and you get a full screen
4K YouTube video going and locked in
space or even in an environment it looks
great it's razor sharp like I could
totally watch YouTube videos like this
but you will definitely be missing like
the features of having the dedicated app
like offline video honestly to me the
killer app of the Vision Pro isn't just
an app it's actually the ecosystem and
we knew this was coming but the second
you log into a Vision Pro with your
Apple ID immediately it starts pulling
all the services and all the stuff that
you're used to from all the other Apple
devices you already have and I said this
before the vision proos announced I was
like this is the most obvious strategy
for Apple because there are lots of
people out there who have never
considered buying a VR headset that are
considering only this one because they
have an iPhone and this is the one that
works with the iPhone and none of the
others are particularly close so all of
your iMessages are already here all of
your photos are already here and loaded
up and backed up all your notes are
already at your fingertips you already
saw the keynote app but okay easily my
favorite feature is connecting to your
Mac right so anytime your Mac is in
front of you and it's turned on hit that
arrow and then there's this little icon
to become my Mac's virtual display so I
click that and then pick my Mac and it
pretty much instantly it actually blacks
out the display of my Mac and then turns
that display into a 4K window inside of
the headset so now my keyboard and
trackpad still work even if it is a
desktop the keyboard and the trackpad
still control everything and you can
continue using it just like a normal
computer but with the ability to make
your new 4k monitor as big or as small
or close or far away as you want which
is super sick and then the bonus is you
can still open up and place other Vision
Pro apps around your Mac computer so
like you can have your Mac in the middle
here maybe you're editing or doing some
work on the Mac App and then you have a
safari window or or messages or whatever
else you want right next to it around it
and then your keyboard and trackpad can
move seamlessly between them all to
control all of them this to me as a Mac
User the ease of use for setup to make
this happen this feels like the biggest
game changer like the most compelling
futuristic feeling use of this headset
to me especially on on a plane oh my God
I can't tell you how many times I've had
an awkward conversation because like I'm
editing a video on the plane the person
next to me sees I'm editing a video of
myself and it's kind of weird and hard
to explain but I'm picturing putting the
headset on the display blacks out but
now I can do all the editing I want and
I can make the screen as big as I want
so I've really enjoyed using that
feature again the biggest challenge
though is still remembering to look
exactly at the thing you want to control
so aside from typing on the real
keyboard on on whatever windows open if
you want to control something you have
to be looking at it again it doesn't
sound like a big deal but when you try
it you'll see what I mean and then also
odd limitation one monitor only from the
Mac one virtual monitor only at a time
so if you usually run like a dual
display setup like I do for Final Cut
Pro big preview on one side timeline on
the other side you can't do that you
have to use the big one monitor version
of your setup all right so you might
have realized I've left one thing out
this whole time one thing you could call
it one more thing sure it's one more
huge crazy thing but it's kind of the
defining characteristic of this product
and that is personas so in all the
advertising you've seen a Vision Pro
there's these eyes on the outside of the
headset that looks like they're kind of
in like a pass through like in a dark
astronaut helmet type of thing easily
the most memed most unique aspect of
this headset right it's the only headset
with an outward display and I mean it's
very very prominent in those videos but
in real life as you've started to see
from some of my footage it is very
different and I think I figured out why
so first of all it's not actually
seethrough right there's a whole bunch
of computer in between me and you right
now so the eyes aren't on the outside
it's a representation of my eyes based
on what all the sensors on the inside
are seeing it's reconstructing it on the
outside so Those sensors are tracking at
90 frames per second and they give you
optic ID which is it's how you log into
the headset and keep things secure it's
basically the same as face ID or touch
ID it's just looking at and identifying
your eyes and it also Powers the One
beta feature of this headset which is
personas which is it's the most
impressive and weirdest thing about this
headset at the same time I'm calling it
right now so the purpose of the eyes on
the outside is really not for you the
wearer of the headset in fact you'll
never see it but it's for the people
around you so when you're in a pass
through mode your eyes will shine
through to indicate that you wearing the
headset can see the person outside so
that right there is already pretty
unique but then when you're in something
immersive and you can't see what's
around you it covers up your eyes with
this sort of like a blue purple glowing
animation so that intuitively makes
sense you can see the eyes when they can
see you you can't see the eyes when they
can't see you but crazily enough there's
also a feature F where if you have
someone who's outside the headset
looking at you talking to you and you
are in an immersion but you want to talk
to them through that they will kind of
appear through the fog of whatever
immersive environment you're in so you
just start talking and looking in their
Direction it detects that and sort of
Parts a little bit of a fog and that
person's eyes will show through the fog
it's pretty decent it it basically only
shows one person at a time and when this
Isen happening on the outside of the
headset it shows a little bit of your
eyes poking through the purple and blue
glow it's as you can see it's it's all
working but also I think it looks
nothing like the eyes from the ad so in
an effort to make the the eyes as
presentable as possible two things first
of all this screen is actually behind a
lenticular film uh which I didn't even
realize that from the initial media
they've published but if you've ever
heard of that it's sort of what gives it
like this 3D depth you might have seen
this on other like holographic displays
and stuff but the point of that is to
make the eyes appear to be sunken into
the display like on your actual face
instead of like glued to the front of
the headset which would look a little
more weird but then two to represent
your actual eyes they've built in a way
to scan in and create a digital
representation of your face which is
called your persona and it looks like
this so to get those eyes on the outside
of the Vision Pro headset you have to do
something called registering your
persona this is how it creates the
digital version of you that includes
your eyes that will show up here so
let's do that now it's actually kind of
a cool process so I'm going to put it on
and hopefully the screen recording works
so you can see exactly what I'm doing I
hit the digital Crown I'm going to go to
settings and you can do this when you
first set it up but I'm going to
Persona and I'm going to hit get started
so let's refine my hands real quick
captures this is capturing detail from
the front of the headset of the hands in
front of
me once it's done with that you remove
Vision Pro it's going to ask me to take
it off so this when you're ready hold
Apple Vision Pro at eye
level keep your arms and shoulders
relaxed align your entire face within
the frame my face shows up like face ID
slowly turn your head to the right
now slowly turn your head to the
left now tilt your head
up then tilt your head
down next let's capture your facial
expressions smile with your mouth
closed then make a big smile with your
teeth
showing now raise your
eyebrows Close Your Eyes For a
Moment capture
complete put Vision Pro back on to
continue I will do that so now I have a
menu that says creating
Persona and it says it's in beta and now
there's there's my Persona right there
kind of
uncanny the hair is a little bit
different but the
face wow wow okay so there's different
lighting you can choose it to always be
in studio lighting and always be in
Contour lighting I'll just leave it at
natural and hit next you can change the
color temperature of your skin tone cool
to warm I think I'm around there
brightness
Darkness I think I'm around there near
the
middle next and then I can add glasses
so if I typically have glasses which
obviously I wouldn't be able to wear in
the Vision Pro you can still look like
you have glasses anytime you're on that
FaceTime call and then
next uh safe and that's
it so I think
now you should see my
eyes
maybe and that that that's the thing it
barely shows up you can barely see my
eyes when I'm wearing the headset now
I've tried a couple other scans
subsequently so I've tried different
lighting conditions I've tried different
backgrounds simple backgrounds tried
different shirts and things like that it
doesn't really ever appear any brighter
I think if you have a darker skin tone
like me just don't expect the eyes to
show up very brightly on the outside of
the headset it's pretty subtle even when
it does show
up it's a little weird looking the eyes
are a little too far part sometimes
they're a little dim you see like one
eye at a time it's it's kind of weird
but that Persona
though that is some pretty interesting
stuff it's crazy that this is actually a
real thing being shipped like first meta
started doing it now Apple's doing this
this is again is technically in beta so
I don't know there's room for
improvement but it still works but as of
right now I feel like this is both
incredibly impressive and slightly
unsettling like it's it's very
impressive that this thing this headset
I'm wearing on my face is tracking every
all these little micro expressions and
little movements for my eyes and my
cheeks and my mouth and everything but
at the same time it's just quite not
quite human it's right at the edge of
the uncanny valley of I'm not looking at
a person
so yeah but the crazy part is you can
now use this Persona as your camera feed
for any apps in Vision Pro that require
a front-facing camera like FaceTime and
so I've tried I've been using FaceTime a
few times in The Vision Pro and it is
technically speaking incredible so I've
made a few FaceTime calls in the past
few days with some fellow reviewers who
you'll probably recognize from their
personas who are also testing the Vision
Pro and universally once we all got past
the shop of oh my God it's it's you it
looks like a digital version of you this
is crazy I've never seen anything like
this before once we got past that there
is a ton happening here so you can see
the FaceTime Windows literally appear as
just that they're just like glassy
Windows floating in space with people
looking through them and then the angle
that you look into the window is going
to match the angle that they see you
looking at them meaning if we're all
envision Pros on this call unlikely but
hear me out if we're all envision Pros
uh and you've got a bunch of people on
this FaceTime call so there's somebody
to the left and somebody to the right if
I look to the person and make eye
contact with the person to the right the
person to the left sees like the side of
my head because I'm looking at somebody
else that's already pretty cool and then
the same thing is true for hand gestures
so we try this out turns out you can
reach out and make hand gestures that
are tracked by the cameras in this
bubble in front of you and they show up
at the correct angle towards the person
that you're gesturing at so not towards
everybody else on the call oh wait wait
okay good test so wait Justine do you
see this yes and Bri I don't see that I
don't see that Marquez now wait so now
Brian do you see this now I can see that
Marquez and then on top of that spatial
audio here is incredibly welldeveloped
so again you're on the call the voice of
the person to the right comes from the
right side the voice of the person to
the left comes from the left but also
you can just pick up and move the window
around and that angle will match where
the people are in the room and where
their sound and video comes from if I
put you on the other side of the room it
sounds like they're further away and if
I turn up the environment and bring them
into like the moon or some other 3D
space it actually sounds much more like
I'm in a gigantic space with no Echo
versus in the actual room it's all very
subtle but very well considered so once
you're in this a while you start to
notice all these these little smaller
things again it's not quite humanlike
it's not like looking at a video feed of
a human
face but it is still like it has a lot
of like this would be the best Avatar
anyone's ever made in 2K like no one's
ever done a 2K face scan and had it look
this good but it's still not as good as
like a perfect reality it's a you've
heard The Uncanny Valley thing before I
think the number one weakness for the
avatars or the personas that I've seen
is hair so basically everyone I've
talked to has like a frozen lump of hair
instead of flowing realistic hair and
that's true about all flowing things
like however your hair was when you did
the scan it's frozen that way and so is
any necklace you're wearing whether it's
crooked or not or I guess technically
also any makeup you had on or however
you looked when you did the scan maybe
that could be a good thing maybe you did
a scan when you were looking all doled
up and then you get on a 7 a.m. call and
you still look perfect even though you
look like you just woke up in real life
so I guess I guess there's that too but
anyway all that is say FaceTime FaceTime
is the most well con wellth out like
most
futuristic Vision Pro experience it just
is so I'll end this video with this now
you know what it's like to use and
operate the Vision Pro but there's still
a lot more to consider when actually
considering if you should buy and own
this thing from the use cases to the
things that work well and don't work
well the philosophy behind it the prices
all of that stuff that's what's going to
be for my full review like there are
parts of this thing that are absolutely
amazing unparalleled best I've ever seen
but the reason it's so interesting is
because it's actually a young category
like we're so used to this slow boring
iteration in mature categories like
smartphones and laptops and you always
see the comments talking about how Tech
is so boring but now they're actually
jumping into something risky and it's
actually fun and there is downfalls and
PA and it's fun to actually weigh the
pros and cons so I'll be expanding on
all these way more in the full review
but I'll leave you with this I've got my
upsides and downsides to Vision Pro it's
been a week upsides some of the stuff
that's the best I've ever seen in a
headset immersion placement in space eye
tracking and hand control pass through
ecosystem and spatial audio and the
downsides weight and comfort the eyes on
the outside abs selection right now
battery life and price so the full
reviews and The Works definitely get
subscribed to be among the first to see
that when it drops either way till the
next one thanks for watching catch you
later
[Music]
[Applause]
peace